hey guys it's Pete peppers here with
candy crush soda saga tips and this is a
jelly saga level 43 walkthrough with
commentary it's a level everyone keeps
asking about and getting frustrated with
and I played it a lot of times to see if
maybe there were some other strategy
because I saw a lot of people were
complaining that I had some bombs and a
combo in my video but I gotta tell you I
don't really think there is you got to
setup a bomb it's gonna be like one of
these and then you gotta gotta be you
got you got it like actually plan to how
you're gonna use it too because in this
case I went ahead and used it right away
because there really wasn't any way to
get rid of some of those coils below but
I can tell you another times whenever I
was playing that the coils you know if
you don't get it right away you don't
have a lot of moves so the coils down in
the bottom can prevent it from really
spreading a lot of the jam so a couple
other key tips that I came up with when
I was playing through it again if you
cover if you can get the top covered
completely that helps out later because
then you know the fish are gonna go down
and help you down there obviously
whenever you're playing through you want
to hit the the coils and when you can
because they're gonna fall aggressively
from the top if you don't so you know
like right there I hit the hit the coils
no more coils fall in same situation
here and if you can get a little bit of
gap in between sweet where you have
quite a few specials on the board and
you know obviously fish in this
situation will help because I can't make
any actual matches in the bottom if you
can get a little a little gap like that
so where they're not going to fall right
in after you do it then you can go back
and clean up like I'm doing right now
you know I have a few coil
above that none on the bottom so it's a
pretty straightforward if I plan out my
matches and I'll be able to finish it
right here on the last move so it's
definitely frustrating like I said I had
to pay it play it quite a few times hang
in there and until you get a bomb don't
really go for much else you know make
sure you're hitting those coils some
more don't don't jam the top up but
really just look for a bomb in a combo
and when you do it take a second to
think like do I do I want to act right
now or is there some other stuff I can
do first in order to get it clear so
that when I use my combo it'll it'll
cover more go ahead and get the whole
top covered and then you know just try
to stop those coils from falling down so
that you can clean up the bottom half
and use your fish to finish the level so
I hope this helped please like the video
I'm gonna be adding it to a guide later
today probably so subscribe to my
channel and I will see you soon thanks